what's going on guys this is rob and you
all really seem to love our origins and
power series so we're going to continue
this by doing an origins and powers
video on shang qi i will say this the
powers this guy has are infinitely more
interesting than his origin why because
his origin is pretty straightforward and
not a whole lot going on there see most
characters have really cool origins
right iron man was a weapons
manufacturer who was kidnapped and then
became a good guy and developed the iron
man suit captain america was injected
with a whole bunch of steroids and
blasted with radiation and became
captain america the incredible hulk was
blown up right i mean you get all kinds
of cool things that lead to these
characters becoming who they are shang
chi's origin is actually kind of boring
so the thing about this is that sheng
chi was raised in the hunan province of
china and was basically the son of a guy
named fu manchu we'll talk about fu
manchu here in a second because that's
that there's a conversation in and of
itself the other part of this is that
his mom was a white chick and the reason
why is because she was selected because
of her genetic superiority whatever the
heck that means sounds kind of racist
but the whole thing about this is that
fu manchu and this girl had chiang chi
and ever since he was an infant shang
chi was raised with understandings of
two things the first was virtually every
form of martial art that exists out
there along with all the different
weapons forms as well along with the
idea that his father was basically a
great guy who does great things now
eventually he sent on a mission by his
father to kill a guy by the name of dr
petry now petrie is of course
assassinated by shang chi and then along
the way when he was leaving the place he
came across a guy named naylan smith now
naylan smith actually turned out to be a
friend of dr petrie and an enemy of fu
manchu and then he basically tells shang
chi that his dad's a villain and so
shang chi leaves he goes to talk to his
mom and his mom's like yeah your dad's
kind of a dick i always held off on
telling you because you know
reasons that she never really gives
and so because of that shane she goes
and confronts his father only for his
father to reveal that yeah like he's
basically the bad guy he's looking to
conquer the world and in turn subjugated
under his rule because he believes he's
the best person to do so shang chi and
his father get into a fight chiang chi
escapes and off and on over the course
of the years shang chi and his father
fight each other until marvel loses the
rights to fu manchu why because fu
manchu was created by a guy named sax
romer and marvel only had the license to
make comics about him and then saks
roamer took him away but ultimately even
if he hadn't done that marvel probably
would have dropped fu manchu because in
all honesty he was racist as hell fu
manchu was like an asian evil sorcerer
caricature from the 1970s given our
understanding of the world and how we
see things now yeah he was pretty racist
to have him especially considering the
fact that the white girl was selected
because of her genetic superiority so
there were some pretty questionable
morally questionable and even ethically
questionable things going on at the time
but that's basically the origin of shang
chi now having said that his origin
sucks so don't be sad if you walk away
and you're like yeah man that origin is
kind of boring as hell it is it really
is
don't feel bad
it's the least interesting origin of
anybody out there but his powers are
cool so chiang chi has no traditional
powers to speak of he doesn't really
have like super strength speed or
anything like that but what he lacks in
powers he makes up for was just a
ridiculous combat prowess especially
because he's able to master his own
energy his own chi this guy knows
basically every martial art in existence
and he knows like every single weapons
form for every martial art in existence
this guy's a one-man army he's a swiss
army knife now the only person out there
in marvel comics that i would say is
probably a better fighter than shang chi
would be task master tony masters and
the only reason why is because tony
masters basically has the ability to
duplicate the moves of others right so
if you fight shang chi for a prolonged
amount of time he's basically going to
be able to memorize shane chee's moves
and actually predict them before shane
chi makes them now it's not necessarily
a catch-all there's been times when tony
masters has been overpowered by captain
america but a lot of that really seems
to do more to the fact to captain
america being just stronger and faster
than tony masters as opposed to like
fighting style versus fighting style but
be that as it may shang chi is wildly
capable in fact outside of tony masters
who usually only trains villains shang
chi is the go-to guy if you want to
learn how to fight it's one of the cool
things that you see in fact spider-man
actually went and trained with shang chi
and learned a martial art style called
the way of the spider now the other part
of this is shang chi is not simply just
a martial arts master there's other
elements about him as well specifically
the idea of meditation now the reason
why this is really important is because
shang chi's understanding and meditation
allows him to tap into his own inner
energy as well as allow people to kind
of enhance what they already have a
really good example of this is captain
universe now you guys don't know captain
universe is it's basically a person
who's bonded with the power of the
enigma force we call it the enigma force
because no one knows anything about it
it just comes from the microverse this
microscopic universe in the main marvel
universe but the whole thing about this
is that when a person is imbued with the
power of the enigma force they can
presumably do anything in the universe
itself including reality warping you
never really see the powers of captain
universe on that scale because usually
the story doesn't call for it but
there's one particular instance where a
woman was involved in a car wreck and it
basically lost her her daughter and i
think her husband and was largely in a
coma for a number of years when the
multiverse was collapsing and captain
universe appeared needing a new host it
bonded itself to this girl and
ultimately shang chi actually kind of
had to help this girl fix her mind
essentially by reliving the past trauma
to understand what had happened to her
and there were a few times when she
would kind of snap back she would lose
it she'd revert back into captain
universe but it was a pretty cool thing
right that's one of the ways in which
shang qi functions but by and large you
only ever really see shang chi in terms
of how he fights and how he bests other
people now there was a point in marvel
comics when shang chi did have actual
powers
and it was amazing so this is one of
those moments where you had jonathan
hickman's avengers and new avengers
which i talked about all the time over
comics explained and you guys will never
hear an instance where i talk about this
and i don't like it so one of the things
that happens here is that the the earth
basically gains sentience by a weird
wonky set of events it doesn't matter
too complex for us to talk about here
but during this process sheng chi gains
the power to duplicate himself and so
there's one point where like the
illuminati right reed richards hulk all
those guys end up facing off against
shield as this led by steve rogers who's
lost the super soldier serum so he's all
old and everything and like he's
literally hunting them down with just
this ferocity right he's just this
crotchy old son of a [ __ ] like he's
just he's just a mean man you know what
i mean just a mean old grumpy man and
like hunting these guys down a great big
huge trap is set by the illuminati which
includes shang chi and it's literally
just this army like this guy who can
just fight in the most prodigious way
ever taking out every single shield
agent and that is one thing that i want
to solidify here despite how cool shang
chi is in terms of his fighting style
the martial arts styles he's capable of
how he can overpower people like black
panther captain america bucky barnes
spider-man things along those lines
despite those capabilities you never
really see him in a large role capacity
in marvel comics in fact all you ever
really see him playing as is something
that kindle like heroes for hire
especially during civil war when he was
tasked with hunting down captain america
on behalf of iron man but despite all
that shanxi's origin it is pretty boring
but his fighting style and his
capabilities are really really really
cool so with that being said guys we're
gonna bring this origins and powers
episode to an end again not a lot to go
on when it comes to shane chi right his
origin sucks and he can fight really
well that's basically it anyway guys
thanks for watching
and i will catch you all later
peace